bonjour pierre manuel thomas de merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui sur arte
france alors ce matin joseph bourrel et
seriez la rof disait vouloir travailler
ensemble malgré leurs différends à ce
que cette décision russe est expulsé des
diplomates européens remet cette volonté
en question je crois qu'il faut séparer
les deux événements il y a une
un mouvement de fond parmi certains
réseaux en europe en particulier en
france mais aussi au niveau de l'union
européenne de poursuivre le dialogue
avec la russie ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
justement avec l'arrivée du nouveau
président américain
pour défendre les intérêts là là une
approche souveraine des états européens
dans leurs relations avec la russie et
ne pas être sous pression des états unis
mais nous voyons aussi qu'il ya une
affaire navalni qui empoisonnent en même
temps ces relations et il n'est pas de
anodin de de constater que cette affaire
navalni arrive justement à ce moment
précis où il ya un nouveau président aux
états unis et il y à des réseaux
atlantis qui essayent de torpiller la
relation entre les européens et la
russie au bénéfice d'une vision
atlantiste pour maintenir la suprématie
américaine en europe et éviter un
rapprochement trop important entre
européens de l'ouest et la russie donc
cette affaire navalni est une véritable
guerre de communication une guerre
psychologique contre la russie monsieur
navalni est en fait créé comme un
opposant à poutine il est il est inventé
je dirais comme un opposant de manière
artificielle pour gêner la russie et
essayer de mobiliser les européens
atlantiste contre la russie et il serait
dommageable que les que les européens
s'aligne sur cette approche
cette opération de guerre de
communication mais te mangerais
maintenant comment vous vous parler de
cette affaire
vanille est ce qu'on peut imaginer dans
les semaines dans les mois qui arrivent
avec l'union européenne d'un côté et la
russie de l'autre fasse un pas l'un vers
l'autre justement pour pour essayer de
s'entendre à ce sujet ce serait
préférable mais pour l'instant il ya une
escalade parce que la russie considère
qu'il ya une ingérence sur son
territoire avec la sphère navalni ou des
diplomates européens soutiennent en fait
ces manifestations alors que la russie
considère que c'est une affaire interne
et et on va plutôt dans la mauvaise
direction aujourd'hui alors même que
l'europe justement avec l'installation
d'un nouveau président européen aurait
intérêt à montrer qu'elle a besoin d'une
bonne coopération avec la russie
parce que le projet européen sont la
russie ne fera pas le poids dans le
monde face vis-à-vis de l'émergence de
cette rivalité américano chinoises et
cette affaire navalni est un grain de
sable qui a été créée de toutes pièces
par cc et réseaux atlantiste et il
serait bon d'avoir la tête plus froide
et de revenir à une coopération plus -
moins dépendant de ces de ces crises qui
sont volontairement provoqué mais pour
l'instant nous avons nous faisons face à
une escalade et il était logique que la
situation à gaza grave parce que la
russie ne se laissera rien dictée
surtout sur ses affaires intérieures
vous parliez justement un stand
de la relation entre l'union européenne
et la russie en quoi une relation stable
est importante
tout simplement parce que d'ailleurs le
président macron l'a rappelé la la
russie fait partie géographiquement de
l'europe
nous avons une culture commune et puis
du point de vue géostratégique dans
l'émergence de la rivalité des grandes
puissances dans le monde avec cette
rivalité américano chinoises qui va
structurer la géopolitique mondiale dans
les années qui viennent
il serait bon pour l'europe russie
comprise la civilisation européenne de
faire contrepoids à un g2
américano-chinois car ils vont dans leur
rivalité ils vont prendre des décisions
sans prendre en compte ni les intérêts
des européens de l'ouest ni ceux de la
russie donc voilà la raison principale
pour laquelle les européens de l'ouest
et la russie aurait intérêt à coopérer
et aussi pour promouvoir des intérêts
communs l'europe est coincé entre deux
arcs de crise d'une part l'acte crise au
sud avec les états faillis l'islamisme
et à l'est
il y à cette fracture entre europe de
l'ouest et russie qui est soutenu créé
renforcée par les atlantistes qui
veulent repousser la russie je dirais en
dehors de la coopération européenne est
justement pour faire face aux menaces
communes le terrorisme l'islamisme les
crises dans l'arc de sud aux crises et
notamment la turquie aussi qui devient
agressive nous avons besoin d'un
rapprochement avec la russie
et évidemment d'en face au co vides à
cette pandémie
une coopération entre l'europe et la
russie seraient bienvenues et d'ailleurs
le le le 25 août nick vient à point
nommé pour pour montrer que il ya une
coopération possible commune en matière
de santé emmanuel thomas
on le disait tout à l'heure on va on va
revenir justement sur cette décision
russe d'expulser des diplomates
européens
quelles peuvent être les conséquences
très rapidement avant de se quitter les
conséquences diplomatiques
alors évidemment il ya les plus
atlantistes ceux qui sont le plus
opposés avec la russie vont réclamer des
sens des sanctions peut-être l'expulsion
de deux diplomates russes
en retour ils vont essayer de demander
sans doute l'arrêt du gazoduc nord
stream 2 qui doit arriver en allemagne
ils vont évidemment renforcé cette
guerre de communication contre la russie
mais j'espère que les pays qui sont
attachées un renforcement de la
coopération au niveau continental vont
essayer de de calmer la situation et
faire en sorte que cette crise ne
devienne ne se renforce pas parce que
les îles est une illusion avec l'arrivée
du président américain que toutes les
relations transatlantiques vont être au
beau fixe que la situation va être comme
avant où l europe et les etats unis je
dirais vont imposer une espèce de
domination occidentale exporter la
démocratie libérale et multiculturaliste
monde entier c'est une illusion totale
parce que les etats-unis défendent
toujours américain first derrière ce
nouveau discours sur le multilatéralisme
le rapprochement entre les européens et
les européens vont se rendre compte que
ils devront devront à nouveau essayer de
se concerter pour arriver à plus
d'autonomie stratégique
merci beaucoup permanente aux fans
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
sur arte france rappelle que des
professeurs en géopolitique et fondateur
de re continent merci beaucoup